PROFESSOR: Senior political
officials of the Roman state
had to take auspices before any
major political event like elections
and before a battle.
They would draw on the expertise of
an augur from the College of Augurs.
Membership of the College
of Augurs was for life,
with new members elected periodically.
Two of the main kinds of auspices that
were deliberately taken involved birds.
One type involved watching for the
flights of specific kinds of birds--
eagles, vultures,
buzzards, or woodpeckers.
Or listening for the cries of birds--
crows, owls, and eagles.
You had to work out whether
the birds were good or bad,
and this was determined
partially by where
they appeared in the sky in relation
to a grid that crisscrossed where
the viewer stood, the
height at which they flew,
and the speed and noise
of their wing movements.
The other main method of
bird divination involved
observing whether or not
the sacred chickens ate
the food that was given to them.
You had to take auspices at
night, and they were valid
only for the day to come.
So if the activity you are taking
auspices for was continued or delayed,
you had to repeat them.
Even though you are only looking for a
yes or no on the timing of the event,
the law was complicated and open to
interpretation and to challenges.
Even if the day had been cleared for
the activity, other offices of state
could claim to see spontaneous
signs from the gods that meant
that the event had to be canceled.